c'est cela qu'il faut regarder micola
yves qui est le front le plus proche
d'odessa qui se situe à une centaine de
kilomètres d'odessa les troupes russes
accentue la pression sur cette ville
parce qu'effectivement c'est le dernier
verrou avant de pouvoir considérer un
dedans avant de voir considérer une
offensive sur la ville d'odessa et puis
c'est important aussi pour les russes
parce que ça leur permettrait bien de
couper la route qui va d'odessa à kiev
en prenant cette ville de micola yves
donc ça les forces ukrainienne
évidemment en ont bien conscience et
elle oppose une très forte résistance
dans la ville de nicolas yves elles ont
même réussi il ya quelques jours à
lancer des contre attaques donc c'est à
dire être al'avantage alors ce qu'il se
passe pour l'instant et bien on sent que
les troupes russes ont décidé de prendre
leur temps alors ils accentuent la
pression via des tirs d'artillerie sur
la ville ça on le voit de plus en plus
des tirs d'artillerie sur des positions
militaires mais de plus en plus
fréquemment sur des positions civiles et
là on voit bien la stratégie russe qui
consiste à pousser le plus en plus
d'habitants à quitter les villes parce
qu'on le constate il y a des problèmes
côté russe pour manoeuvrer en ville ici
ce sont à chaque fois des villes de
plusieurs milliers d'habitants et on
voit que le combat urbain et bien pour
ce qui est du combat urbain les russes
se rencontrent quelques difficultés
quand vous allez dans les villages où
ils sont déjà venus où ils ont déjà
essayé d'attaquer vous voyez bien que
les russes attaques souvent manoeuvre
souvent par les routes principales où
ils rencontrent une résistance
ukrainienne équipés de missiles
antichars par exemple donc c'est assez
compliqué pour les russes de manoeuvrer
en milieu en bas et c'est la raison pour
laquelle encore une fois ils prennent
leur temps et il entend s'y fie la
pression via des tirs d'artillerie donc
ce qu'on constate ici sur nicolas yves
et bien c'est ça c'est une ville qui est
en train d'être épuisé par les russes
avec l'objectif est bien de la vider de
ses habitants avant de lancer une
offensive terrestre